- My mom thought I was
crazy when I told her I was
into underwater hockey,
and she continues to think
I'm crazy when I show up with black eyes.
But she's also my biggest
fan when I'm at the
World Championships.
(jazzy music)
My name is Tyera Eulberg,
and I'm the Captain of
the U.S. Women's Underwater Hockey Team.
So underwater hockey is played six-on-six.
We're not wearing tanks, just
fins and a mask and snorkel.
The puck is weighted and sits
on the bottom of the pool,
and players use a short
one-handed stick to play the puck.
Unlike ice hockey there is no
goalie in underwater hockey,
and the snorkel helps you
watch the play while you're
recovering on the surface,
but otherwise you're holding
your breath when you're
actually involved in the play.
(jazzy music)
We take underwater hockey very seriously.
The U.S. Women's National
Team compete at the
World Championships.
They're held every two
years, and they bring in
about 25 different countries
to compete to be the
best of the best.
It really is the ultimate
team sport because there's no
puck hog that can just do
everything for your team.
Eventually that person's
going to have to come up
to breathe, and you have
to have a teammate there
to take your place.
If I'm about to score, and
I'm running out of air,
I'm gonna freakin' score.
We see people coming to
underwater hockey both from
swimming backgrounds and
from ice hockey backgrounds.
We struggle from the fact
that most people in the
United States don't grow up playing it.
People don't grow up holding
their breath and trying to
kick hard underwater.
They grow up playing soccer
and playing basketball.
There's no money in underwater
hockey, so we're absolutely
doing it for the love of the sport.
I love underwater hockey.
It's so elegant.
Being underwater is
just a beautiful thing.
I feel like some really
gorgeous sea creature
when I'm playing.
(jazzy music)